[Music]
hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Gran Turismo sport is finally here it's
a landmark occasion the first GT title
on ps4 it's been 4 years since the last
title the weight has been difficult for
many of us and with many other driving
Sims on the market it may be a tough
choice to re-engage with the Gran
Turismo brand with that in mind here are
12 things I think you should know about
GT spot the only place we can start is
by looking at the cars lots of cars
around 162 ats lodge with more arriving
in bundles and special editions each of
which have been built from the ground up
to match the real-life counterparts the
brand's you know and love are here such
as Aston Martin BMW and McLaren and even
Porsche aren't getting in on the act of
this time around debuting in Gran
Turismo sport if you are a regular to
the series you'll notice that that is
over 1,000 cars less than GT 6 and if
sheer volume of vehicles are your thing
you may be a little disappointed GT
sport has decided to abandon the same
vehicle with my new differences and
instead allows you to micromanage the
car but we'll get to that very soon the
cars are broken down into six classes of
vehicle which had then broken down again
into more subsets based on horsepower
the lowest level end series are
basically stock production cars ranging
from lowly n 100 through to 1000
horsepower hyper cars the classes are
continually broken down in this way
we've raced vehicles and supercars added
along the way until Group X is
discovered which houses vehicles so damn
sexy it should be illegal this group
consists of concept vehicles which don't
always exist in the real world using
future technology and design so where
will we be racing these buttes across 17
locations and 40 track layouts these
include the Magnificent Nurburgring
Brands Hatch and Suzuka of course brand
spanking new tracks will be here and the
return of some fun favorites too
the time of day can be modified by the
gamer want to race at dawn or dusk it's
one click away sadly this could be seen
as a step back from GT five and six
which offered a dynamic weather cycle
adapting on-the-fly was a fantastic
feeling and sadly it appears to be gone
this is most likely a framerate decision
as a visual drop will pull gamers out of
the moment and the feeling of immersion
it's a massive shame the dynamic weather
is not here the GT campaign returns to
the series but it's another huge
departure from what we were used to the
dealerships where we could buy pre-owned
vehicles and slowly build up to opening
a full garage of garage if you prefer
competing in races has been removed in
favour of driving school mission
challenge and circuit experience driving
school handles the basics of using a car
with mission challenge developing your
skills in scenario based maneuvers
usually in real race conditions circuit
experience is all about becoming
familiarized with every inch of every
track most of these game modes only
utilize a tiny portion of each track a
simulation racing is all about trial and
error and finding the extra tenth of a
second at each corner so where abouts is
the traditional campaign mode go well I
believe it has been replaced with the
online focused sport mode this is where
GT spot shines and is an absolute joy to
play as I'm speaking I'm actually
waiting for a race to begin I can't fast
track it I have to wait for the official
start time as do all the players in the
race while waiting you can post the
qualifying time so your place on the
grid will be higher but I personally
like attempting to go from the back of
the grid and see where I can finish as
your skills improve setting a qualifying
time will be needed to stand a chance in
the race which are extremely sweaty at
times as this is the main mode for GT
spot you shall indeed need ps+ to play
under constant internet connection so
keep that in mind
GT spot also features a few online
championships a real legit trophy will
be lifted at the end of both the
nation's Cup and the manufacturers Cup -
to clarify the nation's Cup is all about
the country you represent and the
manufacturers Cup is about the
constructor so if you really love your
Aston Martin v12 Vantage GT then you
know you should be representing let's
make sure we double down on this next
point GT sport is a simulator it's a
full simulation of real racing so the
rkd elements are so minut that it will
scare the pants off many people playing
for the first time
luckily assistance is at hand primarily
the markers that help you line up your
car at each corner but the braking
assist is a godsend at times if like me
you are terrible at driving then be sure
to keep the assist on but when you feel
like you can on the road turn them off
and be the expert you know you are Lewis
Hamilton watch out fella as mentioned
earlier the customization and tuning is
where those tenths of a second can be
found every single little element of the
car from suspension to tires to engine
tweaks are here to be adapted and
changed just like previous GT titles
it's dependent on the vehicle you want
to tweak a course as each vehicle has
slightly different capabilities to
manage we all know the true way to get
to the front of the race is to stand out
from the crowd then change your
aesthetics of your car the colors and
the decals here check out what
PlayStation access created using their
time with the editor we'll be able to
upload our own images so expect to be
offended by people's artwork as they
race past you the photo mode Gran
Turismo is famous for is here in spot
with a considerable step up in quality
the photo mode is Crossgates this time
around and has almost 1000 photo spots
to choose from many of which are from
real locations many of us will love the
ability to change the shutter speed and
focal length in the pursuit for
perfection and then share it on social
media and be the envy of your friends my
favorite part of recent GT titles is the
rally option and I'm delighted to say
it's back again suddenly it still isn't
a large portion of the game but I do
think it's not worthy
the handling is so different that it
does feel like a separate game at times
another piece of brilliance is the use
of psvr a racing simulator is the
perfect home for virtual reality and it
does not disappoint looking around for
your opponent is surprisingly daunting
but to you drivers who can keep it on
the road it is a must try sadly and
frustratingly this will only be
available as a one-on-one Arcade Mode
extra which will be soul destroying to
some players so that's it GT spot the
attention to detail is second to none
and the sport mode is close to
perfection racing against other drivers
is truly brilliant sadly a few
shortcomings are evident - with less
cars than usual a cut-down campaign and
a VR mode which isn't really part of the
full experience what do you think of GT
sport are you picking it up I would love
to know your thoughts I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]